now that the war is over we need to
discuss what we will do
next any more
ideas
[Silence]
are you going to
go which one
let
[Silence]
in
youe
[Silence]
let go find
them
you know I deserve to be the prince of
yen
I'm stronger than you and smart I have a
stronger Army now so I can defeat you
and your
army you shall have a fight if you wi
you can take over the
kingdom you get to take
the
yeah your mom said I can't go to the
freaking car you can I
[Silence]
can
he he decides to
kill the king said I am not going to
rest until I until I SP on BL and
Chas when ala heard the news he shake
his head and put it in a bag he got some
dirt of Y and put it in back he sent it
to King Nashi with the message saying
this is my hair I send it to you and
this is the land of you you can step on
it when when AB the
church
he when the church he
he
he decided that
he he decided that
he the of the church he decided that he
could gather people
to after up the church he decided that
he were
[Silence]
thank
you from the heard about heard about
so he sneak into the church bathroom and
then
everything Army
and many tried to
stop
[Silence]
yeah I about
the let's see what happens you can have
your C
back
[Silence]
all right thank you very
much